bien bon bonjour à tous et et bienvenue
à Paris ici à la Mutualité pour ce
conseil national donc je voudrais vous
présenter les comptes d'ensemble de
l'année 2015 puisque nous les avons
remis il y a 3 jours très exactement à
la Commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et du financement de la vie
public vous rappelez aussi des grandes
du budget 2016 et vous faire un rapide
point sur l'état d'avancement du budget
2016 vous faire un point sur la dette de
notre mouvement parce que je sais que
c'est un sujet qui vous préoccupe et qui
vous intéresse et puis comme l'a dit Luc
chattel vous proposez deux modifications
de notre règlement
intérieur alors en ce qui concerne la
présentation des comptes d'ensemble de
l'année 2015 un point sur les sur les
recettes pour vous dire que ces recettes
étaient en hausse globale de 5 % grâce
notamment à des dons qui étaient en
hausse de 68 % puisque les dons sont
passés de 4,8 million d'euros à 8
million d'euros en 2015
et je veux à ce sujet remercier notre
président puisque d'ailleurs dès l'année
2014 sur le seul mois de décembre il a
été élu fin novembre nous avons fait
un/ers des recettes de Don sur l'année
2014 à la suite du retour de Nicolas
Sarkozi vous le voyez ça s'est confirmé
en 2015 merci merci Nicolas Sarkozi
parce que évidemment ça compte beaucoup
dans le redressement de notre situation
financière et puis un point sur lequel
nous sommes tous très ATT c'est la
cotisation des élus vous savez que nous
avons demandé aux élus d'être
exemplaires et nos efforts commencent à
porter leur fruit puisque en 2015 les
cotisations des élus ont augmenté de 81
% passant de 1,6 à 2,9 million
d'euros alors il fallait pour redresser
notre situation financière à la fois
stimuler nos nos recettes mais également
mettre en place une politique d'économie
c'est ce que nous avons fait puisque les
dépenses ont baissé de 9 % 9 % en 2015
avec des charges de personnel qui ont
baissé de 13 % et je veux remercier ici
vraiment l'ensemble de nos équipes qui
ont fait beaucoup en étant moins
nombreux une baisse des intérêts
financiers c'est les premiers effets
positifs du remboursement de notre dette
de 4 % et une baisse des dépenses de
structure de 6 % qui comprennent
notamment des coûts immobiliers en
baisse et des frais généraux maîtrisés
donc merci à nos équipes du siège
national merci à vous aussi dans les
départements pour ce beau résultat 9 %
de diminution de nos
dépenses ce qui donne pour l'année 2015
un excédent qui a progressé de 55 % à
6500000 € avec une trésorerie parce que
c'est très important de pouvoir gérer
notre trésorerie sur l'année en hausse
de 50 % ce qui nous a évité de faire
appel aux banques notamment dans les
périodes un peu un peu creuses le
financement des primaires qui est assuré
puisque nous avons avons pu dégager une
avance de 800000 € en décembre pour la
Haute Autorité de la primaire sur les 5
millions d'euros prévus et nous avons
provisionné 2 millions d'euros à la
demande de nos experts comptables et
puis je vous en parlerai dans quelques
instants l'année 2015 a également permis
pour la première fois de commencer le
remboursement de notre dette en ce qui
concerne l'année 2016 vous avez voté ce
ce budget l'année 2016 avec un certain
nombre de de principes de règles
d'orientation la première je la rappelle
c'est très important vous qui venez de
de partout en France on en a d'ailleurs
discuté j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
arriver jusqu'à cette salle parce que
les trésoriers départementaux voulai me
parler de leur situation dans leur
département et c'est très bien les
secrétaires départementaux ou les
présidents également mais je leurais
rappelé je vous rappelle l'arrêt que
nous avons mis en place des 2/3 1/3 et
c'est une règle qui doit vous convenir
puisque c'est pas 2/3 pour le siègeal et
1/ pour vous c'est l'inverse c'est 1/3
pour le siège national et 2 tiers pour
les fédérations à chaque fois vous
faites une cotisation à chaque fois
qu'un élu p paye ces cotisations d'élu
les 2 tiers vous reviennent dans les
départements donc je crois que ça devit
vous aider dans les années qui viennent
à vous rendre plus autonome et à
développer les politiques dans les
départements en comptabilisant la
dotation de l'État nous avons perçu 80 %
de nos recettes à la fin du mois de mai
2016 vous voyez qu'on est'est pas
inquiet pour nos recettes pour l'année
2016 un point important parce que j'ai
entendu que certains étaient inquiets
quant à la façon dont on mobilisait
l'argent du mouvement je veux rassurer
tous ceux qui seraient éventuellement
inquiet puisque en ce qui concerne les
dépenses de fonctionnement au 31 mai
nous avions consommé 42 % de notre
budget or si vous faites une règle sur
l'année ça correspond très exactement à
5/1è des sommes qui sont inscrits dans
le budget qui devaient être consommé
donc on suit parfaitement s'agissant des
dépenses du mouvement notre feuille de
route le budget 2016 permet également de
financer la primaire le campus et
l'action préprésidentielle et ça inscrit
depuis le début ça reste inscrit dans
notre budget et le remboursement de
notre dette alors pour terminer sur ce
point et s'agissant la dette du
mouvement vous avez ici un petit
graphique qui vous montre que cette
dette qui était de 74,5 million d'euros
en 2014 est tombé en 2015 à 68,7 million
d'euros en 2016 à 62,5 million d'euros
et nous allons poursuivre cette
politique ce qui nous permettra dans
très exactement 1 an d'avoir diminué
notre dette à hauteur de 55,2 million
d'euros 55,2 million d'euros c'est
exactement la valeur du siège de notre
actif donc vous voyez que le
redressement est bien engagé sur tous
les plans y compris en ce qui concerne
la dette de notre mouvement merci à nos
équipes merci à
vous alors pour poursuivre cette action
de redressement de nos finances avec
vous l'avez compris à la fois rigueur et
transparence le doc document qui est
projeté à l'occasion de cette séance
sera envoyé à chacun d'entre vous bien
évidemment il est proposé pour
poursuivre cet effort de redressement de
modifications statutaires et c'est notre
président du Conseil national qui vous
fera voter dans quelques instants la
première c'est pour responsabiliser
encore un peu plus les élus qui ne
pourront plus participer aux instances
du mouvement s'ils n'ont pas à jour de
cotisation puisque les élus en tous les
cas ceux qui sont membres de droit
participent au comité circonscription au
comité départemental en qualité membre
de droit s'ils ne payent pas leur
cotisation d'élus ça n'était pas prévu
il faut que ce soit inscrit noir sur
blanc s'ils ne payent pas leur
cotisation d'élus ils perdent leur
qualité de membre de droit il ne peuvent
pas siéger dans les comités de
circonscription et les comités
départementaux c'est une question de
morale et il faut que le message soit
reçu par tous 5 sur C oui les élus du
mouvement doivent payer leur cotisation
tous les élus doivent payer leur
cotisation il n'y aura pas d'exception
il ne peut pas y avoir
d'exception la deuxième modification du
règlement intérieur que je vous propose
c'est pour renforcer le rôle des
trésoriers départementaux je veux
vraiment les remercier parce qu'il faut
un travail absolument formidable et tout
ce que l'on a fait au niveau national il
faut évidemment maintenant que ça
s'applique au niveau
départemental avec deux modifications
une première qui concerne la nomination
des trésoriers départementaux par le
trésorier national ça n'est pas la plus
importante et une deuxième qui elle est
beaucoup plus importante et qui prévoit
que désormais les trésoriers
départementaux présenteront les comptes
du département le budget prévisionnel et
le budget exécuté chaque année parce
qu'il est normal que les militants à
travers leur conseillers au sein des
comités départementaux soi parfaitement
informés à la fois du budget
prévisionnel et de la façon dont le
budget a été exécuté c'est une mesure de
clarté de transparence et de rigueur que
nous nous imposons au niveau national et
qu'il faut maintenant aussi appliquer au
plan
départemental alors pour conclure
j'aurais quelques remerciements et puis
Luc vous fera voter ensuite si ça veut
bien non alors cétait il était prévu
qu'on vote maintenant là c'est pour ça
que ça marche plus mais c'est pas grave
voilà on
continue est-ce qu'en régie on peut
faire avancer le powerpo s'il vous plaît
voilà je voudrais en conclusion donc
remercier comme je l'ai fait le
président Nicolas Sarkozi remercier les
membres du comité financier qui sont se
sont réunis régulièrement les trésoriers
départementaux le Bureau politique
Frédérique pchnard également et
l'ensemble de nos équipes au centre
national et dans les départements et
puis surtout je voudrais vous remercier
vous tous qui et bien quotidiennement
vous battez pour faire vivre notre
mouvement ce redressement financier il
est aussi le vôtre un grand merci à
vous je crois que vous pouvez
effectivement applaudir Daniel parce que
Daniel est un trésorier de poigne
on peut en témoigner hein pas de note de
frais les déplacements à nos frais voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on redresse le parti
alors je vais porter à vos suffrages les
deux modifications de statut qui vous
sont proposé qui sont à mon sens sous le
saut du bon sens et qui vont dans le
sens d'une
responsabilisation des élus qui ont des
devoirs vis-à-vis de leur fédération
première modification pour
responsabiliser les élus qui ne pourront
participer aux instances du mouvement
que s'ils sont à jour de cotisation il
s'agit de l'article 2 du règlement
intérieur où nous ajoutons un 5e alinéa
seuls les adhérents à jour de leur
cotisation et le cas échéant de leur
cotisation d'élu peuvent siéger au
comité de circonscription et au Comité
Départemental le délégué de
circonscription et le secrétaire
départemental doivent respectivement
veiller à la bonne application de cette
règle alors on vous a remis à l'entrée
des petits cartons avec une face bleue
et une face rouge si vous souhaitez
approuver cette modification de
l'article 2 du règlement intérieur je
vous demande de présenter la face bleue
de votre carton qui est
pour qui est contre en présentant la
face
rouge est-ce qu'il y en a qui
s'abstiennent en levant la main et bien
chers amis cette modification est
adoptée à la quasi unanimité
merci concernant la deuxème
modification pour renforcer le rôle des
trésoriers départementaux et pour une
meilleure information financière de nos
comités départementaux il s'agit d'un
ajout à l'article 121 du règlement
intérieur qui concerne le trésorier
départemental en application l'article
57 paragraphe 2 des statuts du mouvement
le trésorier départemental est nommé par
le trésorier national sur proposition du
Comité Départemental il peut-être démis
de ses fonctions par le trésorier
national après avis du comité
départemental en application de
l'article 58 paragraphe 2 des statut du
mouvement le trésorier départemental est
responsable de la préparation et de
l'exécution du budget de la Fédération
devant le comité départemental et le
trésorier nation
il présente chaque année devant le
Comité Départemental le budget
prévisionnel de la Fédération avant le
31 décembre de l'année précédente et les
comptes définitifs de la Fédération
avant leur remise au trésorer nationale
dans les délais légaux requis pour
l'établissement des comptes annuels du
mouvement le dernier alinéa me semble
une modification importante parce que il
peut arriver qu' a pas toujours de
présentation des comptes devant le
comité départemental qui est pour
qui est
contre qui
s'abstient merci pour la modification de
ces
statuts